but I wanted to go back to something you
said earlier about you know the fact
that uh you know that she's a woman
she's this she's this she checks off all
the boxes the Democrat Party should have
been in love with her uh that only works
if you also uh Follow The Narrative but
if you have your own mind your own
thoughts and your own opinion I don't
care how many boxes you check off I mean
look at me I'm black I'm a woman I grew
up dirt poor on a pig farm in Southern
Alabama underneath a rock you would
think the Republican Party the Democrat
Party would be like we love her you
would think that Republican
establishment would be like praise the
Lord now we have a fighting chance to
stoke some enthusiasm in our party but
if you don't follow the narrative
and the script it doesn't matter how
many boxes you check off they don't want
to have anything to do with it yeah but
put it simply if you're not a controlled
puppet you're not going to get any play
and support by The Establishment but I
also want them on either side